jubilee
reunimos a siete propietarios de perros
soy dueña de un perro es dueño de un
perro soy dueño de un persona de un
perro soy dueña de un perro soy dueño de
un perro soy dueña de un perro
uno de ellos es un impostor y el grupo
descubre quién es el impostor se
repartirá un premio en efectivo
[Música]
si el impostor sobrevive gana todo el
premio
bien es el impostor
así que a los perros me llamo roger carr
soy diana ella es velas hoy germán este
sol y vanessa y este stand soy yo quilla
y despacha soy abigail y es que como soy
tris y este giro siempre han sido dueños
de perros si en realidad es mi primera
vez antes no te gustaban claro siempre
me ha gustado pero quiero decir la
escuela es mi primer pero la verdad es
un perro esta bici mi novia no puede
tener hijos así que este es nuestro bebé
y se lleva todo el botín recrecida con
perros toda mi vida sabios que ella era
sorda antes de tenerla no fue como un
trato de drogas y luego descubrieron que
ella era sorda si vas a fingir no llevas
a un perro sordo un perro con
discapacidad así que pensé que era
legítimo tuvieron antes del giro pero
siento que este es bueno mi primer perro
como adulta así que definitivamente es
una experiencia diferente esta vez es
como totalidad
[Risas]
[Música]
parecía un poco callada
era tan atenta con el perro que yo
pensaba que tal vez tenía que ser tan
atento porque no era su perro the
tourist sospechaba un poco porque no
interactuaba con su perro en absoluto
tenemos un empate y el empate está entre
trick
abigail y vanessa ya cada una de ustedes
va a tener 20 segundos para exponer su
caso si mi nombre es vanessa este es mi
perro tan lo tengo desde hace 15 años
tiene un instagram tank samudio si
quiere seguirlo
lo quiero mucho es mi mejor amigo y no
sé qué haré sin él cuando se vaya pero
obviamente esta es que ccoo ha decidido
traer a ella y no a mis otros perros
porque es la que se porta mejor puedo
mostrarte algunas señales de manos y eso
ayuda que ccoo allá arriba no si
es que tengo muchos perros y les aseguro
que soy dueña de perros al cien por cien
muy bien soy tris estás hero deletreado
h&r o en realidad tengo su nombre
grabado en este collar mucha gente nunca
ha visto encárguese antes supongo y
estarán súper emocionados y dirán o esto
me alegro el día así como creo que es
impresionante tener un cachorro que
también hace feliz a otras personas así
como a mí misma
ah
o muy bien buena suerte chicos dios
creo que me sentí un poco rígida y tal
vez eso hizo que todos pensarán que no
estaba interactuando lo suficiente con
mi perro esta será la ronda de trucos de
perros siéntese
derecha
buen trabajo
buen chico abajo buen chico rueda rueda
hace una cosa rara de hoy y 2
no quieres hacerlo
y les juro que lo hace chicos
gira gira gira y vamos abajo rueda rueda
sí buen trabajo amigo siéntate toca
chocar los cinco buen trabajo a veces
que german era sospechoso porque su
perro era muy bueno y parecía muy
profesional con la forma en que lo
estaba manejando pensé que era un
entrenador chacha sentada de abajo
buena chica ella quiere elogios diga
buena chica
[Música]
abajo
y ciro
[Música]
fue más flojo con su perro pensé que tal
vez no era un verdadero dueño de perros
[Música]
william hemos un empate me enteré germán
y aquí sabía todos estos trucos teníamos
esta química como jolie y pensé que
sería como él es bueno él no es el falso
y cada uno tendrá 20 segundos para
exponer su caso muy bien bueno de verdad
soy dueño de perros sabía todos esos
trucos cuando era niño porque no puede
sacarlos después de todas sus vacunas
así que le enseñé todos esos trucos solo
para estimularlo mentalmente es mi
recuerdo favorito de él porque sé que
dijiste antes que probablemente el
aprendió a subir y bajar las escaleras
es como la cosa más linda como cuando
era un pequeño cachorro sachs es mi bebé
soy su dueño la salve de taiwán y eso es
lo que hace que sea tan difícil para
hacer trucos ella realmente no toma muy
bien el entrenamiento le enviamos a un
campamento de entrenamiento porque era
agresiva con otros perros realmente es
un milagro que sea capaz de hacer esto
adiós adiós
me decepcionó porque soy una persona
competitiva y pensé que iba a ganar
por favor levanten la mano si todavía
tienen dudas y quieren seguir jugando en
pero estaba buscando un perro yo estaba
en el mercado de facebook y luego la vi
allí como por 100 dólares fue hasta
riverside y entonces ella comenzó a
mover su cola y a correr así que yo
estaba como esto es felicidad amigo los
cookies son lo mejor que les dan de
comer es esa bolsa azul pastel búfalo sí
blue búfalo solía alimentarlos con eso
ahora reciben la mezcla de pollo de
purina que se ve como otra marca de lujo
al principio no sabía muy bien de qué
marca era la comida así que me dio un
poco de desconfianza todas las mañanas
le cocino pollo vivo ni porque se
enfermó en algún momento la gente cree
que cuál es la película de perros
favorita de tus chicos la mía de niño
era árbol en realidad no me gustan las
películas de perras me gusta marley y yo
pero puedo decir cual no me gusta no me
gusta así porque me rompe el corazón que
creen que es lo más especial de su perra
es muy amigable con cualquiera para mí
ha sido principalmente un gran apoyo el
apoyo emoción creo que el mío es un mimo
so antes de dormir así que él solo no lo
entrenó solía hacerlo pero ya no más
pues para mí mi perro es muy
es como desde que era un cachorro nunca
fue hiperactivo lo que más me gusta es
como acepta a los perros y humanos que
conoce es una chica buena
[Música]
y parecía muy muy nervioso
y me dio la sensación de que era una
entrenadora
[Música]
adiós chicos dios espero adiós hoy de
acuerdo bien bien vamos por favor
levanten la mano si todavía tienen dudas
sobre el impostor y quieren seguir
jugando con seguir jugando sí
solo tengo una pregunta rápida los
registros de vacunación que vacunas
tienes actualmente en todos tus perros
como con el mío tengo pargo moquillo que
es la de hb y luego la de rabia tenemos
la barba y la rabia él tiene la rabia y
no sé el nombre exacto porque nunca he
trabajado con perros sinceramente no las
conozco de memoria eso no significa que
no sea dueña de un perro también porque
puedo revisar la tarjeta de vacunación y
no tengo que aprenderme las pero tú
sabes las vacunas a de todos tus perros
si ese sospechoso alguien que supiera
todo sobre los perros como si hubiera
estudiado sobre ello tal vez fuera el
verdadero impostor entrenas a los perros
en realidad no entre no quiero decir que
entreno a mis perros también y voto muy
grande ros yo me siento muy cómoda con
ellas entonces como es sorda tuvo que
tomar clases especiales para aprender a
comunicarse no en realidad mi novio hizo
la mayor parte del entrenamiento para
ella específicamente y después de eso me
enseñó todo para que pueda responder
como si le das un golpecito para que te
mire excepto que no quiere está enfadado
sas está legalmente a tu nombre o el de
tu no de mi novio
de acuerdo tal vez es que ella no es
dueña de un perro y solo trae el perro
de su novio una pregunta para ti dijiste
que no trabajabas con perros pero antes
dijiste que eras como un veterinario
atenten o asistente gente en una clínica
veterinaria pero antes era auxiliar pero
solo para gatos llevo a mi perro porque
ella atiende a los perros en otra
clínica pero si no entiendo
sentí que se esforzaba por ser dueña de
un perro así que eso me hizo pensar que
podría ser la impostora
a ojo
y se cerraron a días no soy el impostor
pero bueno por favor levanten la mano
según tienen dudas de haber atrapado al
impostor y quiere seguir jugando en 3 2
la única razón por la que quería
continuar es porque dijiste que era de
un hoyo pero dueña de un perro sigue
siendo así lo sé ese caso podría ser un
punto en contra pero lo soy solo elegí
traerla específicamente así que si
hubiera traído a otro de mis perros
seguiría siendo el mismo tipo de
términos seguiría siendo la dueña y si
alguno de ustedes ha tenido alguna
experiencia en la que fuera una
emergencia y haya tenido que llevar a su
mascota al hospital tuve un pitbull más
grande antes de que muriera y tenía un
chihuahua más pequeño y estaba afuera y
lo mordió así que tuve que llevarlo al
veterinario tarde y
tal vez sea una entrenadora tal vez es
profesional como ella hace esto
[Música]
día 10 viejo
chica con vivendi espero que llames a
los pero promete estuvimos cerca
creíamos que íbamos a ganar estaba
triste pero está bien estoy orgullosa de
lo lejos que llegamos si las luces se
ponen en verde significa que han
expulsado al topo y que has ganadas y la
luz se vuelve roja significa que el topo
sigue en la caja y pierdes
[Risas]
podría el falso dueño del perro dar un
paso adelante y revelarse en
pero todo es cierto ella es de taiwán
realmente le enviamos a entrenar pero es
la perra de mi hermano y yo la cuido
todo el tiempo así que pasó mucho tiempo
con ella y es muy dulce puedo jugar con
los billetes contantes
vamos a ganar
[Risas]
[Música]